everyone's talking about actually in all
of the United States and in big parts of
the world but especially here in Los
Angeles what's going on in Hollywood
right now you know the times up movement
right well your take on this whole thing
I think it's great you know you know
that women are speaking out and but man
is it's like every week we get a do
predator or do you know someone else is
being accused of doing these horrible
accident you know harassment and and so
I'm like I can you know I know we have
throwback Thursday but I'm ready to
start it's Monday but it breaks on a
Monday right so it's so many guys out
there I'm ready to start a fantasy
league be honest with you you want to
start a fantasy like is what the
printers great predators and there's yes
yeah well of course being like hobby
wise thing would be the Tom Brady of the
I would pick him but yeah it's awful man
it's awful what's happening and and you
know and what really bugs me when I hear
men say boys it's a hardest rough time
to be a man right now I'm like we shut
the hell up
it is a rough time the same bike that's
the problem y'all have been having too
good of a time you know you can't work
pulling things out and locking doors and
everything I think that's the problem
they've been having too much fun right
right right
but I will say this though Conant and I
know it's wrong but I'm gonna say it if
our guy I probably will whip my thing
out - I probably do it but but not in a
sexual way it would be fun
it would be you wouldn't feel like
offended or harassed or anything like
that you know it would brighten your day
you know like if you do something and I
think it's funny or something right I
whip it out a little flank will come out
[Laughter]
morning governor no no it's not like the
cab no some fun stuff with it Andy you
try to see how it goes I'm not I my
penis doesn't look good enough yeah
[Laughter]
pay me later we'll do it later alright
we'll do it later
these are all terrific ideas and I'm not
going to do any of them
[Applause]
you